Peter Beasley Lakes is Kentucky Fried
Chicken wrapped in payback
people eat Kentucky Fried Chicken here
they do you ever welcome to the United
Kingdom where we also eat Kentucky Fried
Chicken what can I do to walk into a
coffee shop tomorrow and they're gonna
think that I'm not American
speaking in any accident is all about
the tune general American tends to
follow the same pattern the same is true
for Southern Ireland like if you're from
Ireland you tend to go up and pitch when
you stress something and then you go
down at the end like so if I'm like
talking to you now Lucy I'm like hello
and thank you for tying my tie Edinburgh
for example which I've been it's quite
soft but generally if you want to stress
something you'd go up in pitch and then
go down like old school foot would be
like yeah who are ya who are ya yeah who
are ya oh yeah take bit I'm sure I think
if you wanted to go in order coffee
tomorrow how would you say it hello
hello mate
can't get up a bit Oh morning darling
what I really want you can help me out
it's unlike a nice cup of tea and a pan
of Chocolat
oh good like I should play a character
like yes sir I appreciate this yes all
right that's great I don't even drink
coffee should I tell you that now that's
I'm so sorry yeah
who is this we're done with it who are
you standing here yeah yeah I like the
suit very much okay yeah you made it
hello every time leave a tone wonder if
he could give accents